these congales are anxiously waiting for
election results some took their prayers
to church they hope for a peaceful
outcome but across the DRC there's a
sense of
uncertainty I witness the
disorganization in chaos there is
nothing good that will come out of the
election machines were not working the
polls need to be
cancelled most of the people in this
camp for the displaced in North K's
provincial capital GMA did not get to
vote conflict in parts of the Eastern
region has been raging for many
years I didn't vote because I'm from
Ruru and they excluded me from these
elections I feel very bad if we'd voted
we could have elected our true
Representatives now there is no one to
protect
us the election commission is compiling
results and asking for patience the
commission is looking into allegations
of
irregularities that may have happened in
polling stations some groups uh
destroyed voting machines and
intimidated election
workers back at the chart some
worshippers blame the government for the
chaos they witnessed they say any
outcome will likely be contentious
Katherine soy Al jaaz
kesta make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz